dans cette édition quelle défense penser
sur le long terme en ukraine qu elle
aide aussi organisé des ministres de la
défense des eaux généraux de 20 pays
membres non de l'otan se réunissent ce
matin en allemagne sur la base
américaine de ramstein les alliés de
washington vont à sa demande se pencher
sérieusement sur la réponse sécuritaire
a adopté dans l'est de l'europe réunion
donc de haute importance se retrouve
tout de suite en direct de berlin pascal
thibaux bonjour pascal quel est l'enjeu
exactement de cette réunion aujourd'hui
et l'enjeu c'est de trouver un accord de
discuter avec les alliés des etats-unis
pour renforcer les livraisons d'armes et
l'armement global de l'ukraine alors
qu'on estime que le conflit pourrait
durer plus longtemps il ya les états
unis déclarait qu est bien le cren
pouvait gagner ce conflit si son niveau
d'armement était suffisant washington a
annoncé hier une rallonge de 700
millions de dollars ce qui porte son
aide militaire pottas jusqu'à présent 1
3 milliard 400 millions et donc à
ramstein il va s'agir de savoir bien qui
peut livrer quoi quand
pascal rendez-vous qui intervient alors
que la presse allemande annonce que que
berlin est sur le point d'autoriser la
livraison de char à l'ukraine ce serait
un tournant dans la guerre
oui effectivement on le sait berlin est
sous la pression de ses alliés de
l'ukraine mais aussi dans le pays il ya
beaucoup de critiques contre les
réserves de l'allemagne contre les
livraisons d'armes lourdes si ces
informations de presse sont vérifiées ce
serait effectivement un tournant la
ministre de la défense christine
lambrecht s'apprêterait donc à rammstein
a annoncé que l'allemagne
approuve la livraison de chars guépard à
l'ukraine il pourrait s'agir de quelques
dizaines d'exemplaires qui sont
actuellement disponibles et à côté de
cela une autre société fabriquant des
arbres hi métal a déposé deux dossiers
pour les livraisons d'autres chars
martres et léopard à destination de
l'ukraine ces deux demandes directes au
gouvernement doit encore être approuvée
par berlin merci beaucoup pascal thibaux
en direct donc eu deux berlin 7